la terre pour bly 26 projets dans la
sainteté à sec mais glissait qu à cette
époque de l'année des zones vertes
claire apparaissent sur cilaos succès
ras de terre poussins légumes rares et
traditionnelles la lentilles de cilaos a
mené à la mort sèche à l'entrée à
l'entrée du village et sur le début de
l'exploitation
donc la première plantation s est fait
ici ensuite on aura en aura une deuxième
partie qui est en fleurs et une partie
du ramassage
j'ai commencé la lentille ça fait vingt
ans j'ai commencé par une petite surface
un demi-hectare ans et d'avoir
l'opportunité d'avoir deux hectares
toujours marrer chargé lentilles et en
avoir avoir voit la joie d'avoir
récupéré ce terrain d'une surface 8
hectares une histoire de famille salué
par ceux ci les anciens qui perpétue
cette tradition du 19e siècle
[Musique]
no 12 de 13 actes et c'est ça qui permet
le fait que le crémage se mélangent se
mélangent métis il ya assez s'est passé
c'est pas des grosses graines
heureusement qu'elle est petite
alors quatre doigts tient le manche et
le pouce de si vous appuyez vous bien
peu plus elena aussi droite rue sur
galets l'élan est affaibli a ou par
contre c'est un travail et qu'il faut
quatre mois ces quatre mois vous êtes
dedans stendhal anti l'ehpad 1 go ni
n'ai pas ramassé on peut pas dire on va
récolter dans le triple vers blancs le
mildiou ou encore la pourriture blanche
les problèmes phytosanitaires ne manque
pas une production traditionnelle
aujourd'hui aidé par le département
bonjour bonsoir aux dons les biens comme
promis nous on vient en fait ensuite la
première france est vue pour monter le
dossier
ainsi dans le cadre de l'aide aux
producteurs indépendants de fruits et
légumes les productions identitaire ou
moins concurrencées par l'importation
bénéficient d'une aide de 3000 euros
avant il y avait il y avait la pomme de
terre choux la carotte et aujourd'hui on
apprend que les parfums les départements
ça ceci un peu avec les arbitres à
cilaos pour mettre la lentille de ces là
dedans c'est une aide qui pourrait qui
va qui va qu'il va vraiment progressé
les arrivées hier les dernières il faut
savoir que la lentille a souffert d'une
maladie la pourriture blanche et donc sa
production a été divisée de moitié et
nous cette année à travers ces
dispositifs d aide du département on a
voulu soutenir cette filière rionnaise
et même s'il permet un ou deux défaites
de projet de mécanisation des pires âge
irrigation donkey permanent une petite
avance supplémentaire pour aller pour
progresser grâce à grasse le département
du haut niveau la cellule on est un
outil de proximité en un outil
facilitateur de gestion administrative
le but du jeu c'est de que tout se passe
bien aussi bien sur la demande sur
l'instruction que au niveau de la
culture pour qu'il ait le plus
rapidement possible la subvention et
dossier et dossier n'est pas allée par
allée pas trop dieye mais il s'avère
après c'est bon il fait plus de travail
mais mon dossier et nous ni raisin
terrain varié de mars à juillet les
semis sont mises en terre et aujourd'hui
vous avez la chance de vivre l'une des
premières récoltes de l'année à grayan
live à paris qu il y avait des jeunes
commencent à arriver
c'est le climat et la formation
géologique du cirque qui lui donne son
goût si particulier
après la récolte et l'extraction le tri
finalise le produit c'est le collectif
qu'il faut ici saluer une association
d'une centaine d'agriculteurs permet
d'améliorer et ainsi de garantir le
produit premier la première machine donc
c'est un trieur séparateur et une
deuxième machine qui s'appelle une table
densimétrique qui va trier par densité
qui va enlever surtout les petits
cailloux
là c'est le débit donc faux la vitesse
que ce pas trop vite pour moi ça très
bien là on a une lentille propres
l'association était cohérent depuis 1993
dans le bus cité bas
de rassembler le matériel pour trier les
antiques parce que c'est comme un maître
des investissements assez lourd pour que
les consommateurs puissent avoir menti
un moment de stress pour monsieur waro
un premier bilan de la saison est en jeu
dès qu'on aura pu ni celle là ça va nous
donner une estimation des déprédations
quelques années ça va nous rapporter
devient pourcentage déjà si c'est bon ou
si c'est pas bon
on verra bien reconnaître les gones lens
il est ravi médaille d'or chez nous ça
mais doivent bien avec nous comme dans
la lentille nat faire des lentilles
d'entacher l'accompagnement de ces
filières traditionnelles a du sens si
vous êtes agriculteurs indépendants de
l'un de ses fruits et légumes et que
vous voulez bénéficier de
l'accompagnement du département vous
savez quoi faire
[Musique]
c'est donc parti pour une bonne saison
mais souvent on pense pouvoir réaliser
son prévisionnel de 3 tonnes de
lentilles sur les 80 tonnes produites
dans le cirque
[Musique]